before we get to this very important
interview one of my favorites of all
time this is just one of the new
interviews that i do live every single
week exclusively on my member block on
daily wire plus my show's member block
includes many new segments all while i
hear directly from you live in the daily
wire chat room click the link in the
description below so you don't miss out
it is like a whole other youtube channel
away from the sensors
just for
you this story
delighted me more than any story that i
have read in weeks
it just came up in the new york post
and the timing was absolutely
magnificent as i sit here sipping on my
psl
delicious thank you to my producer who
got that for me
the great jacob
nebraska man
shatters world record
for longest trip
in a pumpkin boat
that man would be dwayne hanson a
southeast nebraskan husband father of
two
now the guinness book of world records
holder for paddling
38 miles down a river in a gigantic
hollowed-out pumpkin
mr hansen
thank you for coming on the show
you're welcome
mr hansen
what impelled you to carve out a giant
pumpkin and paddle it down the river
it all started
i'm guessing probably 10 years ago i
started trying to grow these giant
pumpkins
and uh
i grow
a lot of stuff i thought i was pretty
good at growing stuff and
it's really hard to grow giant pumpkins
really hard
and so five years ago
i went to portland oregon to a
giant pumpkin growing seminar for three
days
learned a lot of stuff and
and uh finally this year
uh everything came together right so
you'd write everything and
i drew berta and uh
actually i talked in portland oregon
back up i talked to a lady in portland
oregon
that
held the
record at the time
i thought wow this is pretty cool i want
to do this and so that's how it all got
started
when when you decided to start growing
giant pumpkins was it initially for the
purpose of creating the pumpkin boat so
that you could paddle around the river
no
no i had i had no idea that that was
even a thing
um i mean who does that you know
it's just i i talked to this lady and
that's where i got the idea and i ever
since then that's that's what i want to
do and
do you do you
do you think the lady would be
upset with you that you've now taken the
record
no
i don't believe that for a second
um
i wouldn't be upset if somebody else got
this record and i gotta stress
the guinness people have to accept all
my documentation before i'm before it's
actually uh
official so i try to tell everybody that
so well i i hope that uh you know your
press in the new york post your
appearance on this show will help the
case for the guinness world record have
you have you been a kind of guinness
world record fan i mean forget about the
broken for a second was this was this in
your mind at all i'm trying to wrap my
head around it because i think it's
extremely cool and i love the story and
i think frankly this kind of story is
just what makes me love america so much
is that americans are so kind of out
there that they'll just think up one day
hey you know what i'm gonna grow a
gigantic pumpkin and cut it in half and
sail it down the river and get my name
in a book and i just i love the whole
thing but
where does the even the seed pun
intended for that kind of endeavor begin
i don't know i get these ideas sometimes
and
i actually have a new idea now
um
my daughter wants me to grow pumpkin big
enough
so that me and her can get in and go
down the river i'm not even sure i am
not even sure if that's a record of any
kind i haven't looked yeah
i wonder if it's sort of horticulturally
possible that would need to be a
significantly larger pumpkin
it's possible uh according to my phone i
kind of keep up on the giant pumpkin
stuff
um
supposedly
there's somebody in the united states
right now that has one that's doing 2
700 pounds
how big was the one that you sailed in
uh 846.
that's a big pumpkin too but yes over
two thousand bucks
yes
that would be that will be if it
if it's true that will be the new
world's record
now are you a are you a farmer by trade
i mean
uh i grew up on a farm but uh a dad farm
but uh i actually uh work for a power
plant i push coal for 11.
what what do your
co-workers think about this
oh they think i'm crazy
and what does your family think about
this
oh my mom hated it she thought we were
all gonna die you know
was it dangerous
i don't no i don't think it was i mean i
had um
people in the boat and i'm the one that
was probably in the most dangerous
drowning in the river you know and i i
wasn't scared about that at all
so now didn't even cross my mind
so now that you've
done it i and i hope it goes into the
the guinness book of world records
is the the next step i guess is to do it
in the bigger pumpkin with your daughter
is there is there anything else on your
mind you say you get these kinds of
weird ideas is there any other goal you
know it's sort of like after a mark
maguire breaks the home run record they
said what do you do now he says i go to
disney world yeah
you know i don't know um
i might have a new idea tomorrow my wife
said one time she's she said it was
really stressful living with me because
she never knows what's going to be next
have you been have you been receiving
other media inquiries obviously the new
york post and obviously this show
worldwide
worldwide it's unbelievable i i didn't
expect this in my wildest dreams
so i just wanted to go down the river in
a pumpkin you know
so it wasn't
you didn't take this on because it has
been said that everyone is going to get
15 minutes of fame in their lives you
didn't take this on so that you could
you know have your name and lights and
do a lot of things
not for a minute uh
i just wanted the record i ain't
interested in any other book guinness
record or anything i wanted this record
it was like the only one i wanted
the timing of your uh accomplishment is
kind of coincidental because for the
past couple of weeks i've been talking
about how much i love autumn and
specifically how much i love pumpkin
spice lattes and i know that those
drinks are really only for 16 year old
white girls in urban areas but i don't
care i think they're delicious i love
the fall it's my favorite season
do you have a kind of connection to the
fall is that why you chose the pumpkin
instead of say i don't know a butternut
squash
the reason being
uh i pollinated this pumpkin i called
her bird all summer
uh i named my pumpkins and uh
i i pollinated june 23rd and
if you know anything about the river if
you're gonna go down that river in a
pumpkin
you're gonna get wet and uh
i stopped or growth i probably could
have got up to a thousand pounds
but
the timing was there and i have
days off of work where i can do this and
everything
and
i still want to do it while i was still
halfway warming
and that's the reason i did it as early
as i did that pumpkin
probably would still be growing in the
garden right now if i hadn't cut it off
so so before i let you go i do also have
that technical question where are you
growing this is just like a this isn't a
giant farm this is just a small garden
outside your house
i live on 10 acres
out in the country and uh
i'd have say total
i plant a lot of stuff like i could
probably feed 10 families
people come get stuff all the time but i
i
i got certain places where i plant these
pumpkins it's the soil is perfect i mean
you do a lot of soil tests you don't
just go throw the seed in the ground it
it it's actually fairly complicated
operation
i believe it i believe it i do not think
that i could grow an 800 pound pumpkin i
don't think i could grow an eight-pound
pumpkin uh i know i know dwayne that you
did not do this for fame and attention
but you do have it now that you've got
the ear of america hundreds of thousands
potentially millions of people listening
to you do you do you have anything you'd
you'd like to say
not really
all i'd have to say is anybody that's
listening if you've got something you
really want to do
don't let anything stand your way you
just gotta do it absolutely love it
dwayne truly one of the most delightful
american stories i have seen in a very
long time uh congratulations i uh look
forward to guinness officially
recognizing the record and i look
forward to checking back in on your two
thousand pound double pumpkin boat
you bet thanks all right thank you
i hope you enjoyed that very important
interview as much as i did don't miss
other interviews in the member block
click the link in the description and
join the michael knowles show member
block to get that and so much more on
daily wire plus we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you